people across ukraine are facing a
similar question including here in
odessa a city where russian forces are
right on the doorstep if your homes are
threatened do you flee or stay and fight
well people here are choosing the latter
option as you can see these are
civilians learning how to use
firearms we are here at the polytechnic
university in odessa and that's where
the national defense military training
center is based and for the past three
weeks the military has been offering
these free classes to civilians every
day teaching people how to use a firearm
a lot of people here have never done
that before so they are taking a crash
course a single day course to learn how
to defend themselves and their families
can you teach them to defend themselves
against
a trained russian very difficult
question
this is something that everyone should
decide for himself
but i think that many of these guys
understand that
if this fight happens this will be their
last fight they don't have that spirit
that we have
we are ready to fight for our family
right now russian forces are fighting
about a hundred kilometers east of here
and are pushing in this direction now
last week city officials said that of
about a million people in this city a
hundred and fifty thousand had fled but
that number is expected to surge
significantly as russian forces draw
closer
jeff sample global news odessa